yo what's up guys it's Q welcome back to
musical dares the show we take this
classic game of musical chairs doing
some disgusting dares we have a good
time all right so right now let's bring
in our first contestant I'm Audrey I
work with kids all the time so I am
definitely amazing at musical chairs and
I saw the dares we'll see what happens
well I heard we're eating stuff and I
hate to be that guy but I'm a vegan so I
don't know if I can participate too much
but if I can I'm gonna do my best
how's it going to Miffy look I'm at the
height of my athletic ability so I know
I'm gonna tear it up but even if I don't
I eat everything so you know what's good
what's up I'm Nadia I'm one of the most
competitive people I know so I have that
going for me I'm Vicki so I'm pretty
competitive when it comes to games and I
love hosting game nights so I think I
might just win but my reaction time is
pretty slow so wealthy the rules of
musical dares are simple we have four
chairs three of the chairs of white and
one of the chairs is red the red chair
is the Dare chair if the music stops you
land in the Dare chair or don't get a
chair at all you're either gonna be
eating some discussing or you'll be
heading home for the day
winner gets 150 dollars cash or a
special grand prize let's get into round
1 let's do it
sorry aw come on no sighs no sighs baby
Alliance is forming already also liar
not happy you guys dancing this is your
spirit be sweet
[Music]
all right so if you pinky
Jared you guys are safe Aubrey
unfortunately you sat in the dare chair
which means you're gonna have to do this
dare right now uh-huh
Nadia and she doesn't want to do it you
will have your opportunity to take it
over sticking this game and get this cat
so when we walk over to this table check
out what we got and you let me know
whether or not you want to try this I'll
do it it looks like paper and that
really doesn't look like thing it has to
be edible right tastes like taco meat
and juice you know the usual
oh you are about that life you're not
afraid to get down and dirty with some
tacos ranked hi-c so unfortunately Nadia
that means we have to let you go because
somebody gotta get this okay we gotta
get back to this so my friend my homie
Nadia she had to go it but somebody has
got to get this money so let's start
round two because I know somebody wanted
oh I like this right this is a small
circle right Jerri if you guys are good
to go you guys are safe girl Aubry
welcome back to the dare table if you
want a piece of this winning cash you
got to eat this diarrhea quesadilla
so what we did was put a little bit of
castor oil on the inside which is gonna
get your stomach bubbling just a little
bit just a little bit it's the safe
amount trust me
I mean I've gotten this far I gotta do
it I have to do it he's about that life
Aubry what's up we got some sriracha on
top we got a little bit of hot cheetos
oh man
surprise for you later today thank you
so much oh it's really stale do I need
to get that big why did I smile yeah
it's not the way it goes in is probably
the way it goes up I'm gonna follow you
on twitter I need to know that's fine
Thank You Aubrey hey you are a G that's
two rounds two dares you are serious
about this money but listen you did it
Vicky unfortunately that means we gotta
go good luck guys alright so
unfortunately Vicky had to go but it's
time to get into round three because we
got three hungry people over here and
they ready to get it
Oh
[Music]
interesting interesting so Jared you are
good to go
iffy good news for you is that you have
a chance to stay in the game but right
now we have a mystery round there's no
food on the table so what we're gonna
have you do is you have to text your
crush and tell them how you really
really really feel Wow and if you don't
want to do it we can pass this off to
Aubrey she can head up her crush and
tell them how she really really really
feel no I'll do it
all right cool I just wait for this text
to come in and it's not a very
impressive you all right
as a matter of fact I'm leaving like
cute bit let's go for the last one cuz I
mean if you talk to them last already
okay okay hey blank I think you're
really cute we're really cool thought
this for a while and I want to know if
you want to grab dinner sometime oh my
and then beat ends all right it's done
yes the message is sent he hit up his
crush and he said with his feelings
shoutout to it feel he's gonna make it
to the next round
unfortunately that means that we have to
see you go Aubrey you were dope but
somebody I get this man yo I cannot
believe all brie got up I don't root for
people but I was rooting for Aubrey she
went through two dares had no issues but
listen that's not how the game goes in
this game you got to be quick on your
feet if you want the seat and she was
not so let's get into round 4 the fun
we got Jared we got iffy somebody by to
get this cash let's get into y'all
alright I don't want to do this to you
because we're like bros and stuff no hey
my guy but like I've also got this rent
coming up yeah and I could say to Gator
boys going at it I have to do this or
I'll get dizzy just like the final
battle of Dragon Ball Z's yeah that's
[Music]
scary
okay me my boy you know the deal you sat
in there you got to do the dare
let's go over to this table and check
out what you got man so look at this man
we got a taco yep we got some anchovies
yep
we got some hot pants I didn't see that
flies oh if you want this money you need
to eat those Weaver ants anchovy taco
right now somebody go dry - I got to go
in dry puts the cards right Jaco let's
discuss but if he just no you don't have
to do this cuz my man Jerad is right
here no I'm always that money dude I'm
always down a clown baby oh yeah I'm
about to put it in she oh my god cuz I
it's the one my one weakness with his
bugs
I don't just don't go into a lot
walk around walk it off walk it off so
fuzzy is it crunchy the sponge right oh
wow man things people are do for money
those guys are not as money
so Jarrod unfortunately you made it to
the bottom round you didn't have to eat
anything so there's no one in there
there is we got to have you go cuz we
got a shower this man with cash time
without you Jerri the game well you know
it's just with the strength of the hips
just because you not the first to start
moving towards the chair not out the
game you just got a you know yeah I got
a lot of junk in my trunk I'm not afraid
to use it and then when it came down to
it I'll text my crush I'll eat some ants
let's go
there you go so what was the nastiest
thing you've seen today me eating those
bugs like it would have been the the
chunky drink but I still feel like bug
parts on my tongue and that's that's
just gonna live with me are we gonna get
an update on the crush how can we find
this out yeah yeah definitely you'll see
if I'm on a date it'll say hashtag there
y'all know what's up
here we go well y'all congratulations
you can take her out to do whatever you
want because you are bald in my firm
yeah
[Music]